Trascrizione: Martina Esposito
Revisore: Sara Pasini
Parto con una domanda.
Vi siete mai chiesti il significato
profondo della parola cura?
Chi di voi come me ha fatto il classico
la ricorderà benissimo
perché è una delle prime parole
che si imparano insieme a rosa rosae rose.
La cura indica una sorta di
interessamento amoroso,
di forte partecipazione che in alcuni casi
può addirittura tradursi in vera
e propria preoccupazione.
In sostanza, la cura non è quel picco di
attenzione che dedichiamo alle operazioni
delicate, come per esempio strapparsi
le sopracciglia con la pinzetta.
Al contrario, è una sorta di
interessamento continuo e costante.
Negli ultimi tempi sui mezzi di
comunicazione
si fa un grandissimo parlare
del lavoro di cura.
Per chi non sapesse di cosa si tratta:
sotto questa parola racchiudiamo tutte
le attività di assistenza, compagnia,
educazione, anche sanitaria, nei confronti
di persone che fanno parte
del nostro nucleo familiare, che possono
essere tipicamente minori,
ma possono anche essere persone anziane,
persone malate o persone con disabilità.
Esiste una fetta della popolazione –
e sospetto, tra l’altro, che non sia
nemmeno una minoranza, convinta che
prendersi cura sia una sorta di talento,
diciamo un tratto scritto nel
nostro codice genetico
come non lo so, gli occhi azzurri
o le gambe lunghe.
La mia esperienza, per quanto breve, mi ha
insegnato che in realtà prendersi cura
è un'abilità e come tutte le abilità
si apprende e si consolida
tramite la pratica.
Non escludo tuttavia che esistano persone
più spontaneamente predisposte
nei confronti del lavoro di cura.
Io sospettavo di non essere molto portata
e infatti nel giugno 2016, quando è nato
il mio primo figlio, voilà, la verità
si è palesata davanti ai miei occhi.
No, non ero molto portata
per il lavoro di cura.
Ciò non toglie che, insomma, mi sia
rimboccata le maniche e mi sia dedicata
a colmare le mie lacune.
Lacune che erano pratiche, ma che erano
anche e soprattutto emotive.
La mia carriera di genitore full time è
durata poco perché il mio congedo di
maternità è durato soltanto sei mesi che,
se ci pensate, sono assolutamente nulla
rispetto a quei genitori che magari si
sono dedicati a tempo pieno ai propri
figli per un anno, due anni, tre anni o
magari hanno ripetuto questo circo
complicatissimo per più figli consecutivi.
Tuttavia, c’è qualcosa che sento di avere
appreso nonostante quest’esperienza breve.
Ed è una cosa che, anche se è
un po’ rude, è un po’ forte,
dico spesso alle mie amiche che magari
aspettano dei bambini, alle persone che
fanno parte della mia community online e
l'ho anche ripetuto più volte all'interno
del mio podcast.
Non importa che cosa tu farai al termine
del tuo congedo parentale, magari
tornerai in ufficio, chiuderai in attivo
il bilancio della “Super Soldoni S.p.A”,
oppure ti chiuderai in una stanza,
scriverai il prossimo premio Strega,
oppure, chi lo sa, magari aprirai una
gelateria e diventerai abilissimo
a mantecare il gelato al pistacchio.
Ma la verità è che una volta che tu vesti
i panni di genitore,
quei panni non li dismetterai mai.
Parafrasando una vecchia pubblicità dei
diamanti, la cura è per sempre.
Tornando a noi, al termine del mio breve
congedo parentale sono rientrata in
ufficio e ho immediatamente toccato con
mano che c'era una certa incompatibilità
tra i tempi del lavoro e i tempi
della mia vita privata,
della mia nuova vita familiare.
E ho subito scoperto l’uso e, francamente,
l’abuso del termine conciliazione.
Apparentemente in Italia la conciliazione
è un tema caldo, è un tema importante
addirittura le è stato dedicato un organo
che si chiama Dipartimento per le
politiche della famiglia che si trova
all’interno della Presidenza del
Consiglio dei Ministri.
Dal punto di vista politico, la
conciliazione indica l’insieme delle
azioni che lo Stato, le famiglie e le
aziende intraprendono di concerto
per mitigare l’incompatibilità tra i tempi
lavorativi e i tempi della vita privata,
con particolare riferimento
ai tempi della cura.
Il mio mito Nanni Moretti dice che chi
parla male pensa male e vive male.
Ed è per questo che fin da subito mi sono
categoricamente rifiutata di utilizzare
il termine conciliazione.
Ancora una volta mi ha aiutato
interrogarmi sul significato profondo
della parola.
Infatti, la conciliazione nasce
innanzitutto come un termine di natura
giuridica ed è infatti il processo
mediante il quale due controparti mediano,
tentano di risolvere una controversia.
Tornando al nostro ragionamento, se i
tempi del lavoro e i tempi della famiglia
devono essere in qualche modo
conciliati tra di loro,
significa che sono
tra di loro contrapposti.
Per facilitare il processo di
immaginazione, possiamo figurarceli come
due forze che trainano, che tirano in
direzioni opposte e che sono tra di loro
concorrenti per accaparrarsi le mie
risorse più scarse, la mia attenzione
e il mio tempo.
Tornando a noi, se effettivamente io mi
chiamo sempre Valeria Fioretta, sia che
stia prendendomi cura di mio figlio
sia che stia lavorando,
e tra l’altro vado anche abbastanza
d’accordo con me stessa,
esattamente in me
che cosa c’è da conciliare?
Ma soprattutto.
Visto che sarò un genitore per sempre,
perché l’abbiamo detto prima,
ma andrò in pensione a cent’anni
e quindi lavorerò per sempre,
questa tensione, questa sorta di
competizione interna tra le due me
ci sarà sempre?
Cioè devo rassegnarmi davvero
a vivere così male?
Anzi, lo chiedo a voi, dobbiamo
tutti quanti rassegnarci?
Ora, prima di concepire questi pensieri
così catastrofici, diciamo,
io ho cercato di convivere
con la mia nuova condizione
e ho anche elaborato delle strategie di
sopravvivenza, delle tecniche di coping.
Quella che utilizzavo di più l’ho
ribattezzata la tecnica del on-off.
Succedeva che alle 9 del mattino mettevo
su off la mia parte materna,
la mia parte amorevole e mettevo su on
la parte lavoratrice e produttiva.
Arrivavano le 18, timbravo il cartellino
e voilà, mettevo su off
la parte manageriale, calcolatrice e
potevo finalmente mettere su on
la parte materna e genitoriale.
Non vi dico la fatica, era stremante,
ed era una fatica fisica,
una fatica mentale e soprattutto emotiva.
E nei giorni no, che non erano pochi,
succedeva che la parte aziendale
si mangiasse, si succhiasse
tutta l’energia
e alla Valeria mamma
non ne rimaneva più niente.
C’erano certi giorni in cui tornavo a casa
e mi sembrava di sentire
un altro mio mito, il regista Sorrentino,
che mi stava dietro la schiena,
mi sussurrava nelle orecchie:
non ti disunire, Valeria, non ti disunire.
Vi chiederete com’è andata a finire.
È andata a finire che un giorno mi sono
svegliata e ho detto basta.
Semplicemente ero stanca, anzi,
veramente ero piena fino qui
di sentirmi una sorta di cassettiera
a compartimenti stagni.
Ero molto, molto stanca di non essere
me stessa 24 ore al giorno,
sette giorni su sette,
e volevo per me il diritto di essere
felice sempre e non solo a targhe alterne.
La soluzione pratica che ho messo in atto
per uscire da questo impasse
non è così importante, nel senso che
è cucita sulla mia persona, è figlia
del mio profilo professionale, della mia
attitudine al rischio, dell’organizzazione
familiare che mi ha sostenuta e non ultimo
anche del mio privilegio economico.
Però nessuna fase di questa rivoluzione,
di questo mio cambiamento
sarebbe stato possibile se non avessi
fatto un importante step preliminare
che è stato guardare alle persone della
mia vita con occhi diversi.
Per primo è toccato al mondo dell'azienda.
Quindi gli imprenditori, i manager,
i capi, i colleghi,
persone che mi volevano in un modo
dalle 9 alle 18, poi pretendevano
che fossi in un altro modo dalle 18 in poi
e che insinuavano, in modo neanche velato,
che la maternità mi avesse instupidita,
mi avesse rammollita.
Poi il mio sguardo si è fermato sul mio
partner che in alcune occasioni,
molto poche, gliene devo dare atto,
ha cercato di farmi sentire sbagliata,
come se questo mio desiderio di riunirmi
fosse una sorta di bizza da viziata,
o cercato, magari in alcune occasioni,
di farmi sentire in colpa
perché non abbracciavo la mia nuova
condizione in una maniera abbastanza
spontanea ed entusiasta.
E infine ho guardato uno ad uno
tutti i miei amici, cercando di capire
chi era mio alleato, cioè chi mostrava
rispetto e amore per la mia persona tutta.
Nella consapevolezza di quanto è stato
importante questo amore
e questo rispetto per la mia integrità,
da quel momento in poi ho deciso che mi
sarei sforzata con tutte le mie energie
di essere una vera e propria alleata, cioè
un'alleata delle donne che, come me,
ancora cercavano di riunirsi.
E non lo faccio perché penso di essere
arrivata chissà dove nel mio percorso,
che anzi non è assolutamente
esaurito, ma perché penso che quello
che io ho fatto sia una rivoluzione che
può e deve essere alla portata di tutti.
E in questo modo mi piace pensare che
svolgo un doppio lavoro di cura:
a quello nei confronti di mio figlio,
che nelle varie fasi era fatto
di pannolini, ninna nanne e biberon,
si affianca un tipo di lavoro
di cura che ha come destinatari
le persone adulte
che ancora cercano di riunirsi.
È un lavoro che è fatto fondamentalmente
di ascolto, è fatto di presenza,
è fatto di parole e di esempio attivo e
che ogni giorno mi restituisce tantissimo
perché ogni giorno mi fa sentire
capace di cura,
che è un altro modo per
dire capace d’amore.
Grazie a tutti.